back with the fox news alert president
trump averting a government shutdown
signing the massive 2.3
trillion dollar spending bill which
includes 900 billion dollars in
coronavirus relief
the emergency funds in the relief deal
include 600
payments for every adult and child an
extra 300 a week in unemployment
benefits
for 11 weeks 284 billion dollars in
funding for paycheck protection program
and extending the eviction moratorium on
capitol hill today congress will vote on
the president's demand for
two thousand dollar checks to every
american
those checks the major sticking point
between republicans and democrats
it's terribly untargeted right why would
we be sending two thousand dollars to
people with a six-figure income who've
had no suspension no reduction of their
income at all
given the terrible uh economic crisis
facing this country yes
we do need to get two thousand dollars
out to
every working-class individual in this
country
so did president trump's strategy help
or hurt democratic strategist robert
patillo and political analyst ron meyer
join me now to discuss
robert what do you think did the
president help the situation or hurt it
he hurt the situation let's understand
that president trump had the ability
to come out over the summer or even in
the spring and say that he was going to
demand two thousand dollar
uh direct payments to individuals why
would you wait until the entire bill has
already been negotiated and passed
in order to throw a monkey wrench into
the middle of it these checks could have
been going out this week according to
treasury secretary mnuchin
but it's been delayed because of the
president's uh
breaking down and stopping these
negotiations and trying to do this in a
separate bill we know that we're going
to have republican recalcitrance so of
course he hurt this process
ron what do you think is robert right or
is this all nancy pelosi's fault from
again
back in the summer for demanding a
gazillion dollars not the official
number but it sure felt like it
in her relief deal well that's it i mean
we can play the blame game all day but
trump supported
two thousand dollar plus payments for as
long as i can remember certainly going
back to june
and yes yeah the democrats did pass
something but it was filled with every
sort of writer and spending package
that was their dream including bailing
out states that haven't been smart with
their money
and so you know i think we can go back
and forth and blame and say well it
could have been done earlier we all know
this the democrats were never going to
pass a bill
before the election that the president
would actually be able to sign and so
they put it they filled it with stuff
that would make it totally unsignal
because they wanted to make sure that
nothing passed before joe biden
was able to secure victory and so that
was that's been their strategy from day
one
and so i think the president you know i
think the president supported these big
checks for a long time he still supports
them he'd support a standalone
writer that increases it to two grand i
think he i mean at this point
no one's really caring about federal
spending and the president certainly
understands that i think he feels like
direct payments
are you know giving people their money
back and so that's really the least we
can do when we're sending money
across the world to various foreign
countries all right let's let's switch
gears to topic two now the president
firming up his georgia rally
plan for the day before those critical
runoffs there in the peach state
what do you think robert do you think
the stimulus signing is going to sway
voters in any way shape or form or is
this
are the results in this one already
baked in well the issue is that you've
had kelly lawful are spending a half
billion dollars on commercials
criticizing rafael warnock for wanting
to make direct payments to individuals
and now a week before the election
president trump coming out in favor of
the exact policy that rafael warnock has
been in favor of for the entirety of the
campaign
kelly loffler consistently throughout
this pandemic has worried about
enriching herself
the same way that her husband jeffrey
betzer did in 2008 until
2009 with credit default swaps that
caused the great recession
so these people have consistently
demonstrated they feel the direct
payments to the american people are
unnecessary but to help millionaires and
billionaires is what they really care
about
i don't think president trump is going
to change that over a sudden trip to
georgia next week
ron your response listen i think that
both of the current incumbent senators
voted for the relief i think they've
supported additional relief from time to
time
and what it comes down to really is
momentum and people wanting a true check
on government you know when the
president-elect gets sworn in
january 20th people are going to want to
know there's a check and balance and if
the democrats hold both the house
and the senate and the presidency i
don't think that's what the american
people want i think they want divided
government they want to make sure
that that dc is forced to compromise and
that one party doesn't run rap shot over
another and if you look at these georgia
senate races i think that's what it
comes down to and especially when you
have candidates on the democratic side
that really aren't in line with sort of
moderate compromising values they're
really
you know very hardcore progressive
democrats and so do we really want the
senate to be taken over
in that way when we have when we could
have one party control i don't think so
and i think that's
that's why you're going to see president
trump go down there to try to get some
momentum for the republicans
to close this thing off and i think that
republicans do have the slight momentum
here
it's going to be close and you have to
wonder if the president really just
held his nose and swallowed his medicine
here because even though he hates the
pork in his bill he doesn't want to do
anything which distances
the two republican senators there and
potentially it's all about making them
lose
all about georgia it's all about robert
and ron here on a monday morning we
appreciate your time and your insight
gentlemen carly over to you